[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तू जो
वेलकम टुडे
सो डेट की मुझे पता चल जाएगी
हेलो हेलो
आवाज क्लियर है अभी बैकग्राउंड
सेटिंग
तो अच्छा नहीं लगता यार बट ठीक है फिर से
हम वही बात करते हैं एक बार फिर से आप
हमारे हम आपको याद दिल देता हूं की आप लोग
भूल गए होंगे रे की आपके सबसे पहले
क्लास मेरे भाई क्योंकि मैं अवेलेबल नहीं
था मुझे कहानी जाना था और मेरी फ्लाइट आई
एम नोट एबल तू टेक डी क्लास उसके लिए हम
रियली सॉरी तो आज प्लेन किया है और बात
करते हैं अभी की फिर से मैं आपको याद दिल
देता हूं की जैसे हमारी क्लास खत्म हो
जाएगी प्लीज हमारे इलेक्ट्रॉनिक सर्विस
सिक्योरिटी के लिंक पेज पर जाइए जो की
हमारे युटुब चैनल के जो आज की क्लास है
उसके नीचे लिंक दिया हुआ है प्लीज वहां
जाकर एक बार देखिए तो वहां पर जैसे की
यहां पर डेट है डेट में जो क्लास हो चुकी
है डेट में किसी ने भी अभी तक कमेंट नहीं
किया है तो अब इसका मुझे मतलब समझ में
नहीं ए रहा की जो लोग लाइव आते हैं
एटलिस्ट हो तो कमेंट कर सकते हैं
तो वहां पर जाकर एटलिस्ट आप हमारे लिए 5
मिनट तो निकाल ही सकते हो आप लोगों से
रिक्वेस्ट है की 5 मिनट निक जैसे क्लास
खत्म हो जाए एट लिस्ट जो लोग लाइव ए रहे
हमारे साथ जो लोग हमारी क्लास को देखते
हैं एक या दो तीन कर पांच लोग जितने भी
हैं प्लीज वो जाइए 5 मिनट निकाल के हमारी
वेब पेज पर जैसे अपडेट हो जाता 15 मिनट
बाद 10 मिनट बाद प्लीज उसको जाके एक कमेंट
करके बता दीजिए सो डेट की हमने क्या-क्या
सिखाया इसमें वीडियो में क्या-क्या सिखाया
गया ताकि दूसरे लोगों को पता चला है अब नए
नंबर चैनल पे कोई कमेंट नहीं है फाइव पे
ही कमेंट है सिक्स पे कोई कमेंट नहीं है
तो आई डोंट नो की वही जिन लोगों को
कमेंट है 5 पे 5 पे एक सेवंथ पे नहीं है
एक भी एक भी नहीं है अब जो लोग लाइव आते
हैं
तब तक
जिनको आना होगा ए जाएंगे
तो कभी मुझे पता चल जाएगा
आप अच्छी बात आपने ग्रुप में शेर किया है
आईसीटी मैं देखा है बट एट लिस्ट हमारे वेब
पेज पर जो वेब पेज वाला वहां पर कमेंट
कीजिए
[संगीत]
कम कीजिए जब भी आप लिरिक्स उसे कर रहे हो
खासकर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर और जब भी आप
क्या करते हो एक नया तू एड करते हो आपकी
मशीन में नया टूल आपने इंस्टॉल कर लिया और
अगर वो इंस्टॉल सक्सेसफुली हो गया है तो
एक कम कर लीजिए तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना
है ये हमारे वर्चुअल मशीन है
तो आपको क्या करना चाहिए बच्चों की बॉक्स
में जाके
सिस्टम
में है जैसे की आपने फर्स्ट टाइम इंस्टॉल
किया होगा उसके बाद एक कम करना राइट क्लिक
करो आप और यहां पर जो आप स्नैपशॉट के
ऑप्शन पे जा रहा है जैसे मैंने लिए
जैसे आप क्लिक करोगे
तो वहां पर जी कंडीशन में आपकी मशीन
प्रेजेंट कंडीशन जी कंडीशन है
जो उसके यूजर आईडी है जो उसका पासवर्ड है
जो उसमें एप्लीकेशंस है जो भी उसकी कंडीशन
है उसे कंडीशन के साथ ये क्या हो जाएगी
आपकी मशीन एक स्नैपचैट के साथ छह हो जाएगी
आपने फ्रूट ले लिया अब जैसे की आप
कंटिन्यू कम कर रहे होते हैं जैसे आपने
कोई टूल इंस्टॉल कर लिया आपने कुछ ऐसी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की और वो अच्छे से हो गई
इंस्टॉल कर लिया है कोई भी तू इंस्टॉल कर
लिया अच्छे-अच्छे होने के बाद एक कम कर
लीजिए स्नैपशॉट अगर वो अच्छे से कम कर रहा
है तो सिंपली क्या करो स्नैपशॉट पे फिर से
जाइए स्नैपशॉट तू ले लीजिए और पहले वाले
को डिलीट कर दीजिए क्योंकि पहले वाला सही
से चल रहा है और सेकंड वाले में आपने लिया
कब लोग स्नैपशॉट जब आपने उसे मशीन को आपकी
मशीन हो सही तरीके से कम कर देते इस
कंडीशन
किया अब वे कम से एनीथिंग की टूल में कुछ
मालवेयर होगा
है और वह तो आपकी मशीन में जैसे ही आया और
टूल में आते ही उसने क्या किया उसकी मशीन
की कुछ सेटिंग्स को छेड़छाड़ किया और मशीन
में प्रॉब्लम्स क्रिएट होगी और
पीछे का किसी को पता नहीं था तो स्नैपशॉट
ना लेने का उसको प्रॉब्लम यह होगी की अब
उसने जो सेटिंग के साथ मशीन को ट्राई किया
अब नई वाली सेटिंग के साथ वो मशीन चल रही
है उसने कुछ कंफीग्रेशन की थी कहानी से
स्टेप फॉलो की है युटुब से गूगल से बट
क्या जो हाउस को प्रॉब्लम्स हुई उसकी मशीन
कुछ अलग तरीके से चल रही है जो उसमें अभी
मेरे को वीडियो में दिखाए है तो अगर आपने
स्नैपशॉट ले रखा होता तो ठीक है एक टूल है
जिसकी वजह से प्रॉब्लम होगी आप सिंपली
क्या कर सकते हो जब आपका नेटवर्क ले लेते
हो तो आपकी मशीन में कुछ भी प्रॉब्लम होगी
अगर आगे आपकी मशीन फोन
कर सकते हैं यहां पर देखो यहां पर टैक्स
होता है यहां पर मेरा ये जो आपको दिखाई दे
रहा है ऑरेंज कलर का है जैसे यहां पर
क्लिक करोगे तो जो स्नैपशॉट अवेलेबल 1234
जिसने के साथ आप क्या करना चाहोगे
स्विच करना चाहोगे आपकी मशीन
में से टाइम स्विच हो जाएगी उसे स्नैपशॉट
के साथ तो इससे आपको बेनिफिट ये मिलेगा की
आपकी मशीन में कोई एरर ए गई या आप कोई टूल
कॉन्फ़िगर कर रहे थे वायरस हवा वायरस आया
तो उसकी वजह से प्रॉब्लम हुई तो उसे
प्रॉब्लम की वजह से आपको क्या है की आपकी
मशीन पुरी खराब होगी तो आपकी मशीन खराब
होने से बचाएं क्योंकि आपने बड़ी मुश्किल
से तू इकट्ठा किया हुए बड़ी मुश्किल से
इंटरनेट का जुगाड़ करके डाउनलोड किया
होंगे टूल्स को और चैन से कोई एक ऐसी फाइल
डाउनलोड हो जाए अपने मशीन को प्रूफ कर
दिया तो इस कैसे में ये स्टेप्स इतना गुड
फीचर है की आप बैक तू नॉर्मल स्टेट में
अपनी मशीन को लिया लेकर ए जाएंगे और उसके
बाद क्या है की फिर से उसे 2 के साथ ट्राई
कर सकते हो अगर टूल सक्सेसफुली इंस्टॉल हो
गया तो अच्छी बात है फिर उसका स्नैप सूट
ले लीजिए आप ये अच्छी प्रैक्टिस बना लीजिए
तो आपको मैं मानता हूं की लाइनेक्स मशीन
में खासकर जो म्युचुअल मशीन आप उसे कर रहे
हो तो आपको ना तो कभी बार-बार आपके टूल के
लिए प्रॉब्लम होगी ढूंढना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
आपने शॉट बनके रखें हुए हैं कोई किसी
कॉन्सेप्ट की मशीन क्या होती है प्रॉब्लम
होती है
मतलब उन्होंने
सुन की कोई प्रॉब्लम है तो क्या है
स्नैपशॉट के सारे आप अपनी मशीन को बच्चा
सकते हो और आप अपना टाइम वेस्ट होने से
बच्चा सकते हो क्योंकि मुझे पता है की तू
उनको इंस्टॉल करने में कितना टाइम लगता है
और पुरी मशीन को इंस्टॉल होने के बाद फिर
से वो टूल ढूंढ के करना टोटल टाइम
कंजूमिंग होता है और जो हमारा टाइम वेस्ट
हो जाता है एक प्रकार से तो दिस इसे डी
बेस्ट ऑप्शन ये जिनको नहीं पता था प्लीज
इसको फॉलो की फॉलो कीजिए शो डेट की आप
लोगों को इसमें इन फ्यूचर हमेशा कम आएगा
क्योंकि आज जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर
आपको ये बहुत हेल्प है बहुत हेल्प करेगा
सोमेटाइम्स ऐसे चैलेंज जाएंगे जो हमारे एक
दोस्त के साथ चैलेंज आए हुए हैं और उसके
दोस्त को सच में बहुत प्रॉब्लम
है समझ नहीं का रहा हूं उसके अभी तक इसलिए
हेल्प नहीं कर पे क्योंकि मुझे टाइम नहीं
मिल पाया की उसने कंडीशन मैं समझ गया उसने
तो प्रॉब्लम ये है
तो उसको यह करना चाहिए था तो अभी वहां से
उसके साथ ये प्रॉब्लम हुई है तो बाकी किसी
के साथ ये प्रॉब्लम ना हो तो आप लोगों को
क्या करना चाहिए
हमेशा किसी भी मशीन के लिए चाहे आप
वर्चुअल बॉक्स में कोई भी मशीन उसे करो
उसका एक स्नैपचैट बना के रखिए ताकि आपको
हेल्प मिले तो अब आज हमारे कंटिन्यू टॉपिक
पर चलते हैं आज का हमारा टॉपिक
के बाद
उसको पढ़ना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है
[संगीत]
तो कम चल जाएगा
और सही गलत से बचाने के लिए हमें क्या
करना पड़ता है एक सिक्योरिटी तो मेंटेन
करनी पड़ती है ना तो इस चीज के लिए फाइल
सिक्योरिटी
नहीं होती तो वो गलत चीज आपके मशीन में
कुछ भी गलत कर शक्ति है अगर मैं मोबाइल
सिक्योरिटी है तो वो गलत चीज आपके मशीन
में कुछ भी गलत नहीं कर शक्ति और आज का
टॉपिक जो मैं पढ़ाऊंगा और आज के टॉपिक और
कल का टॉपिक है जो दोनों इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक
आज का टॉपिक तो मैं हो सकता है की हमें
पूरे 1 घंटे में खत्म कर देंगे कल का
टॉपिक आई होप की 130 मिनट चलेगा आई होप है
और एडवांस फाइल सिक्योरिटी के बड़े में
बात होगी
मशीन को हैक करोगे खास करके जो लिरिक्स
मशीन है
तो वो साड़ी चीज क्या होती है और प्रॉब्लम
होती है फिर उनको तो
फाइल सिक्योरिटी
[संगीत]
करना सीखने हैं हम कैसे करते हैं देखो
फाइल सिक्योरिटी
करते हैं कितने टाइप्स की परमीशंस डिफाइन
करते हैं वे परमिशन कौन-कौन सी होती है वो
साड़ी चीज पढ़ने वाले हैं तो देखो फाइल
सिक्योरिटी के बड़े में अभी मैं कम करता
हूं आपके लिए एक स्क्रीन ओपन कर देता हूं
अच्छे से नोट्स बनाने में हेल्प मिले ओके
जिसको बोलते हैं
तो दूसरा तरीका है उसको हम बोलते हैं
एडवांस फाइल परमिशन
बेसिकली दो टाइप के फाइल परमीशंस फॉर्म
उसे करते हैं
बेसिकली आपको ये बहुत साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
आपको देखने को मिल रही है पर एग्जांपल
प्रोजेक्ट में
हम करते हैं
यह चीज
थोड़ा अच्छा नहीं लगा तो मैं बात करता
देखो
डाउनलोड नंबर
अभी आई नोट नंबर क्या होता है हर एक फाइल
और डायरेक्टर
नंबर किसी भी फाइल सिस्टम पर लिमिटेड नंबर
ऑफ आईडी नंबर होते हैं यह डिस्क और फाइल
सिस्टम की कैपेसिटी पर डिपेंड करता है यह
सिस्टम को फाइल को आईडेंटिफाई करने में
हेल्प करता है जब मैंने आपको फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन का टॉपिक पटाया था वहां पर
आई नो टेबल का जिक्र हुआ था अब वहां पर
मैंने बोला था एक आईओ नंबर का लोट होता है
उसे एंड्राइड नंबर की हेल्प से आपको पता
चला है की मेरी फाइल कहां पर हमारे सिस्टम
में स्टोर है और आई नोट नंबर्स यहां पर
रिफ्रेश किया जाता है उसके अंदर क्या जाता
है मेरा डाटा राहत है उसे फाइल का ये सब
मैंने अपनी फाइल क्लास में बताया था
आपके जो फाइल साइज है
ज्यादा रहेंगे अगर आपकी छोटी सी मशीन है
तो उसके बाद कम रहेंगे सेकंड आपको देखने
को मिलेगा ये होती है जो आपको देखने को
मिल रही है इसको बोलते हैं हम फाइल टाइप
और परमीशंस इसके अंदर क्या है की एक तो
पता चला है की फाइल का टाइम क्या है इससे
और इससे बड़ा चला है किस फाइल के ऊपर
परमीशंस फोन कौन सी है ओनर के लिए ग्रुप
के लिए और आदर्श के लिए ओके और जो ये आपको
दो नंबर दिखाई दे रहा है ये देखो शो करता
है की नंबर ऑफ लिंक कितने हैं इट्स सो डी
नंबर ऑफ तू फाइव यहां पर आपको पता है ये
इनफॉरमेशन होती है ओनर ऑफ डी फाइल यह
ग्रुप ओनर होता फाइल का यह साइज होता है
बेसिकली
नंबर क्या होता है अब इसके बड़े में
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं बेसिकली मेरा क्या
है इसी के बड़े में थोड़ा कॉन्सेप्ट है
चलो अब ये रहा मैं इसको उदा लेट हूं
कंट्रोल
भी इसके बड़े में पढ़ने वाले हैं अब जो
फर्स्ट एंट्री है जो आपको दिखाई दे रही
होगी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं एक बार
अलग-अलग कर देता हूं
ये आपको क्या रिप्रेजेंट करती है आपको
टाइप ऑफ फाइल प्रेजेंट करती है आपकी
फाइल परमिशन फाइल
परमिशन फाइल परमीशंस प्रेजेंट करती है अब
इसमें भी क्या है
अब इसमें जो फर्स्ट थ्री एंट्री है जो
पहले तीन एंट्री है कॉपी करता हूं
परमिशन
परमीशंस पर ग्रुप
और ग्रुप के लिए
क्या परमेश्वर
है जो आपको देखने को मिल रहा है ये होती
है
परमिशन
पर
उनके लिए इस वॉलपेपर
यह के डायरेक्टर
क्या है ये कहानी ना कहानी सिम बोलेंगे
अब बात करते हैं हम नेक्स्ट अगर आपको
देखने को मिलता है अगर बी मतलब क्या है बी
का मतलब एक ब्लॉक फाइल है ब्लॉक मतलब कोई
हार्ड डिस्क लगी हुई है या कोई हार्डवेयर
पार्ट है
अगर आपको यहां पर देखने को मिलता है सी सी
का मतलब है कोई कैरेक्टर फाइल चाहिए
कोई सॉकेट फाइल है
तो ये एक सॉकेट फाइल है तो बेसिकली यहां
पर इस टाइप के मार्क्स आपको देखने में मिल
जाएगा ये एक नॉर्मल फाइल है तो
अब बात करते हैं परमीशंस की बात करते हैं
अब ये ए ब्लू एक्स क्या होता है रुस के
बड़े में पढ़ने वाले हैं बेसिकली
रॉक्स आर का मतलब होता है
आप क्या कर सकते हो
अभी इतना तो रहने दे यू कैन रीड
कर सकते हो
या जो जो आप क्या कर सकते हो
अगर फाइल को रीड करना है उसके अंदर क्या
है वो डाटा देखने के लिए आप रख सकते हो
आप बात करते हैं डब्लू की डब्लू राइट
परमिशन फाइल के लिए क्या होता है
मतलब यू कैन
मॉडिफाई थे
मॉडिफाई कर सकते हो
इस प्रोग्राम को रन कर सकते हो उसका मतलब
यही चीज को डायरेक्टरी कंट्रोल सी
और ये डायरेक्टर
स्क्रीन पे करके दिखा रहा हूं
राइट कर सकते हो
एग्जांपल
एग्जिट परमिशन देने पढ़ेंगे डायरेक्टर
परमिशन ऑफ फाइल के ऊपर कैसे कम करती है और
रेड रेड एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन डायरेक्टर के
ऊपर कैसे कम करती है अब बात करते हैं कुछ
न्यूमेरिकल फॉर्म में इंटरनेट परमिशन की
बात कर रहा था जो रेड परमिशन होती है
जिसको हम लिख सकते हैं जो आर है आर को हम
लिखने हैं अगर न्यूमैरिक वैल्यू में फोर
इसके लिए एक फोर काउंट किया जाता है आर के
लिए
और राइट के लिए जो राइट परमिशन है
परमिशन के लिए हम कम करते हैं जो डब्लू है
मैक्सिमम
परमीशंस हो शक्ति है परमिशन और
फाइल या डायरेक्टर
के लिए
क्या होती है
तब तक हम
बात करते हैं की अगर मुझे किसी भी फाइल का
ओनर या ग्रुप चेंज करना हो तो वह कैसे
करेंगे
अगर आपको किसी भी फाइलें डायरेक्टर का
ग्रुप होना चेंज करना है
उसको क्या है दो लोग कर सकते हैं पहले तो
रूट वह कर सकता है दूसरा वह यूजर कर सकता
है जो उसे ग्रुप का मेंबर होगा पर
एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है इस काली की
जगह
क्या है
और इस अगर यह कम करना है अगर आप किसी भी
फाइल का अगर आपको ग्रुप चेंज करना है और
ग्रुप होना चेंज करना है यार आपका फाइल
होना चेंज करना है उसके लिए कमांड उसे
करते हैं उसको मैं आपको दिखता हूं करके
पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है हमारी मशीन
में कोई यूजर है क्या 1 मिनट
करता हूं
फ्लैश डाउनलोडिंग
टेस्ट
[संगीत]
काली उसके अंदर
कॉलेज
है अगर इसको
देखिए आप इसका जो ग्रुप फाइल ओनर
है हमारे पास
क्या है
तो कैसे करूंगा
काली उसके बाद क्या
इंटर
आप चाहे तो क्या कर सकते
हैं एक साथ में दोनों कम कर रहा था तो वो
भी कर सकते हो और एग्जांपल ch4 जो होना ना
क्या कहना चाहता हूं इसका पहले जो काली है
काली क्या रखना चाहता हूं उसका
रखना चाहता हूं साथ में उसका ग्रुप ओनर भी
खाली रखना चाहता हूं सिंपली एक साथ जो
इनफॉरमेशन आई है वो आई है आपकी फाइल ओनर
की नाम ऑफ फाइल ओनर
उसके बाद अगर मैं यहां बताता हूं आपको
क्या है
उसके बाद यहां पर लिखना आपको ग्रुप होना
ग्रुप इनफॉरमेशन
की तो आप परमीशंस कैसे
आप परमिशन कैसे कर सकते हो
चेंज कैसे कर सकते हैं
ओके
ओके कैलेंडर
[संगीत]
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है अब मैं क्या
करता हूं इसकी परमिशन
करके देखें
आपको देखने को मिल रही है रेड लाइट रेड ये
परमीशंस है इस फाइल के ऊपर अगर मुझे क्या
करना है इसकी परमीशंस को चेंज करना है मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं इसकी परमिशन देखो अगर
क्या करना अगर आप किसी भी फाइल्स की
परमिशन को चेंज करना चाहते हैं तो वहां पर
दो मेथड कम करते हैं पहले मेथड होता है
दूसरा होता है अल्फाबेटिकल जो न्यूमैरिक
मेथड है अल्फाबेटिकल में लिखने हैं तो
सबसे पहले मैं आपको सीखना हूं
एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया इसकी परमिशन को
रखना है
बताना चाहता हूं तो रीड के लिए
का सकता हूं क मोड उसके बाद क्या करना
चाहता हूं
सेवन सेवन सेवन उसके बाद ये कभी भी हम
नहीं रखना चाहिए हम प्रैक्टिस कर रहे हैं
इसलिए
दिखता हूं आपको तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा
की फाइल टाइप ये एक नॉर्मल फाइल है रेड
लाइट एग्जीक्यूट रेड एग्जीक्यूट रेड राइट
एक्सिकल ठीक है परमिशन है ये है ऑक्टॉल
मेथड आप किसी भी फाइबर में से पर एग्जांपल
अगर आप चाहे तो किसी फाइल में कोई परमिशन
दे सकता हूं मैं क मोड किया उसे करके और
मैं इसको परमिशन हटाना चाहता हूं मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं
अल्फाबेटिकल मेथड की बात करते हैं
अल्फाबेटिकल मेथड कैसे करेंगे भारत मुझे
क्या करना है की जो मेरा ये ग्रुप ओनर है
यहां से एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन मुझे यहां से
रिमूव कर दिया तो मैं कैसे करूंगा क मोड
और मैं ये का रहा हूं गुरु जी के गुरु के
लिए जी माइंस साइन मतलब मुझे रिमूव करना
है उसके बाद मैं का रहा हूं एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन लगानी है इस फाइल से और क्या का
रहा हूं केरल रोड टक्स कलर टक्स ये टेंडर
अब अगर फिर से करके देखोगे
मिलेगा की मैंने ग्रुप ऑनर्स को क्या कर
दिया रिमूव कर दिया अगर मुझे क्या करना है
तो वो भी मैं कर सकता हूं क मोड
के दिखता हूं आपको इस तरीके से अब यहां से
एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन फैट गई
अब क्या है यह तो रिमूव करने का तरीका
परमेश्वर को एड करना है अगर यूजर्स के लिए
या ग्रुप ऑनर्स के लिए अपना एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन को एड करना तो उसका तरीका होता है
क मोड उसके बाद में कहना चाहता हूं अगर
यूजर के लिए प्लस साइन उसे करना है सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है प्लस साइन एग्जीक्यूट
सिंपली और आपको क्या करना है फिर फाइल का
नाम
आपको
इस परमिशन तो रिमूव करेगा प्लस का मतलब आप
क्या कर
रहे हो
इनफॉरमेशन को एक और चीज उसे की जाति है
उसे किया जाता है इसमें क मोड गेम मैंने
और अगर जो मेरा ग्रुप ओनर है इसकी परमिशन
में क्या देना चाहता हूं ओन्ली राइट
परमिशन देना चाहते हैं इस फाइल के लिए इस
फाइल ओनर को ओके दे सकते हैं तो किसके लिए
यूजर को मुझे क्या देनी है ओनली कौन सी
इक्वल साइन फॉर्मेट डब्लू लिखूंगा इक्वल
साइन का मतलब क्या तो उसकी पुरी पुरी
परमिशन रिप्लेस कर देगा अभी तक प्लस माइंस
का मतलब क्या था की सिंपल इस पर फाइल
प्रोड्यूसर रिमूव कर रहा था लेकिन ये क्या
करेगा
क्योंकि अगर मैं यहां पर ओनली माइंस ब्लू
कर देता हूं ओन्ली राइट परमिशन बनाता है
अगर मैं प्लस ब्लू करता हूं ओनली राइट
प्रदर्शन
क्रेडिटर अब मैं यहां
परमिशन होगी यहां पे जैसे की रेड परमिशन
है अगर मैंने इस पे एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन
देनी है तो मैं सिंपली क्या कर रहा था क
मोड और मुझे क्या करना था ए ग्रुप ऑन उसको
प्लस साइन करना थाi
अंदर क्या कर रहा हूं मैंने जी ग्रुप ओनर
लिखा ग्रुप ओनर के लिए उसके बाद मैंने
क्या कहा जाता है ओन्ली एक्स लिख दिया
उसके बाद kel.c स्टूडेंट अब देखना क्या
डिफरेंस आपको देखने को मिलेगा
सिंपली ये रात
कर दिया
मतलब सभी को एक साथ करना चाहते हो तो कैसे
करोगे
वो भी कर सकते हो पर एग्जांपल आप मुझे
क्या करना है की मैं एक परमिशन रखना चाहता
हूं की रीड राइट परमिशन हो फाइल ओनर को
ग्रुप ओनर को रीड और रीड परमिशन हो और ऐसे
ही ओन्ली
लिखना है उसके बाद ग्रुप के लिए आप क्या
रखना चाहते हो परमिशन उसके बाद एक उसके
बाद कोमा उसके बाद क्या करना चाहते हो
ओन्ली रेड परमिशन उसके बाद
का नाम
देखोगे तो इसमें क्या कर दिया आपके हिसाब
से परमीशंस को चेंज कर दिया एक साथ तीनों
की यूजर ग्रुप ओनर
सिंबल का भी उसे कर सकते हो लेकिन मुझे
डिफरेंटशिएट आपको समझना था की प्लस सिंपल
का मतलब क्या होता है - सिंपल का मतलब
क्या होता है और इक्वल सिंबल का मतलब क्या
होता है
ओके तो यह था एक चीज
के बड़े में चलो ठीक है
फाइल क्रिएट करते हो जब भी एक फाइल ग्रेट
करते हो और एग्जांपल मैंने टच की और उसके
बाद मैंने फाइल क्रिएट
[संगीत]
करता हूं
एक वैल्यू होती है
यह वैल्यू होती है जो यह डिफाइन करती है
की आपके सिस्टम में कोई क्रिएट होगी या
कोई भी डायरेक्टर क्रिएट होगी तो उनकी
इफेक्टिव परमीशंस क्या होगी बाय
परमीशंस क्यों होगी वो इस वैल्यू के
द्वारा ही डिसाइड की जाति है
और सिंपली यू मास्क आप करोगे तो हिट होंगे
तो यहां आपको देखने को मिल रहा है जीरो तू
तू ये आपको देखने को मिल रहा है यहां पर
ठीक है ये आपको देखने को मिल रहा है यू
मास्क तो यू मास की वैल्यू आपको क्या
देखने को मिलती है जीरो तू तू
अगर आप क्या करोगे
कर वैल्यू बनाएंगे
[संगीत]
022 का मतलब क्या है इसके अंदर एप्लीकेशन
ओके
बोनस की परमेश्वर को रिप्रेजेंट करती है
ग्रुप ओनर जी आर ओ यू पी ग्रुप ओनर
प्रमोशन परमिशन जिसका ग्रुप ओनर है पर
मिशन ओके और नेक्स्ट जो है वो रिप्रेजेंट
करता है जो अदर यूजर्स है जो अदर
अदर यूजर परमिशन अदर यूजर की परमीशंस को
क्या करता है ये मेरे प्रेजेंट करता है अब
हेड ऑफिस
की वैल्यू हम चेंज कर सकते हैं क्या सही
रहेगा नहीं रहेगा और यह कैसे कैलकुलेट की
जाति है
इसकी एक टेबल होती है
लेकिन एक बार ये टेबल देखिए
जो टेबल में जीरो का मतलब जो होता है ना
जीरो का जो मतलब होता है टेबल में वह होता
है
रीड
राइट और एग्जिट
होता है
उसका मतलब होता है आपका राइट ओनली
राइट ओनली
राइट ओनली होता है
सिक्स का मतलब होता है एग्जीक्यूट ओनली
इसका मतलब होता है एग्जीक्यूट ओनली
आपको देखने को मिलेगा इसका मतलब है
इसमें जीरो का मतलब उसमें जीरो का मतलब नो
परमिशन यहां पर जीरो का मतलब रेड रेड
परमिशन ये वो टेबल है यू मास की जो पेपर
की जाति है ओके अगर आपको क्या करना है
किसी भी पर एग्जांपल मुझे किसी
ओनर के लिए क्या करना है तो जीरो और सेवन
मतलब बाकी के लिए कोई परमिशन नहीं है तो
077 आप डिफाइन कर सकते यू मास्क की वैल्यू
अब ये कैलकुलेट की जाति है कैसे की जाति
है इसके क्लोजिंग होता है वो लॉजिक मैं
आपको समझाऊंगा और अगर आज आपको ये लॉजिक
समझ में ए गया
इतना हाय सिक्योरिटी
परमिशन कैसे कम करती है
कैसे यह मास की वैल्यू कैलकुलेट की जाति
है
[संगीत]
परमिशन
पर
ये बात कर रहा हूं
कैसे कैलकुलेट की जाति है उसके लिए तो
मैक्सिमम परमिशन
जो आप सेट नहीं करते
हैं लेकिन
अब यह सिक्स सिक्स क्यों देखो
क्या होता है
दी नहीं जाति इसलिए बाय डिफॉल्टर जो
मैक्सिमम परमिशन आप किसी भी फाइल को दे
सकते हैं वो रीड राइट रीडर दे सकते हो
एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन नहीं दे सकते इसलिए
देखने को मिलता है ना की सेवन सेवन सेवन
की आपका सिस्टम
दे सकते हैं
सिक्स सिक्स ओके तो अब कैलकुलेट कैसे करते
हैं हम
आओ तो
कैलकुलेट
इफेक्टिव परमिशन इफेक्टिव
इफेक्टिव परमीशंस
ये कैसे कर सकते हम तो बात करते हैं आपको
क्या करना है सिंपली यू मास्क जो वैल्यू
है
मैक्सिमम परमिशन में से तो हम कैसे करेंगे
नेक्स्ट अगर मैं आपको एक चीज दिखता हूं
डायरेक्टली की बात करता हूं अगर मैंने एम
के दी आई आर किया और कोई डायरेक्ट
अब यहां पे देखो अब बोलोगी फाइल के लिए
चलो समझ में ए गया डायरेक्ट
7557 तो यहां 75 कैसे कैलकुलेट हुई तो
इसका भी एक लॉजिक कम कर रहा है ये कैसे
कैलकुलेट की जाति है
देखो
ओके
मेरा अब जो मैक्सिमम परमीशंस होती हैं जो
मैक्सिमम परमिशन होती है किसी भी
डायरेक्टर के लिए
जो मैक्सिमम परमीशंस होते हैं किसी
डायरेक्टर के लिए होती है 77 मतलब रेड
लाइट
एग्जीक्यूटिव की क्या जरूर है
तो अभी फोल्डर क्रिएट होगा तो फोल्डर से
अटैक नहीं होता
है
क्यों जाति है
किधर जाओगे
लेकिन
अगर एग्जिट परमिशन नहीं होता सीडी नहीं कर
पाते तो डायरेक्टरी कैसे में क्या होता है
और फाइल के कैसे में 6 काउंट होती है
क्योंकि बाय डिफॉल्टर लाइनेक्स में फाइल
को एग्जिट परमिशन नहीं दी जाति लेकिन
डायरेक्ट
में एक्जीबिट परमिशन दी जाति है अब बात
करते हैं देखो तो अब यहां पर यू मास कैसे
कैलकुलेट करें
तो वही है हो तू कैलकुलेट डिफेक्ट तू
परमिशन इफेक्ट तू परमिशन कैसे कैलकुलेट की
जाति है जो वो
ओके हम कर देते हैं सिंपली यहां पर करने
के लिए ओके वही वही वाला सीन है बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल तो यहां पर क्या हुआ 77 -
022 किया और इक्वल किया और यहां पे आपको
मिलेगा 755 जो आपके भाई जो बोल देखने को
मिले अब यहां पर सिक्योरिटी के बाद कैसे
आई देखो पर एग्जांपल
अब एग्जांपल लीजिए की अटैक
की वैल्यू चेंज कर दूंगा तो ऑटोमेटेकली
अगर मैंने कोई ऐसा वायरस बनाया है या कोई
मालवेयर बनाया है वो क्या करेगा की आपकी
मशीन में इंटर करेगा फाइल क्रिएट करेगा
कोई नहीं और उसे फाइल में सबसे पहले मैं
क्या करूंगा की मैं उसकी यू मस्त की
वैल्यू चेंज कर देता हूं शो डेट की मेरी
जितनी भी फाइल है ना उनको एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन मिल जाएगी
टेबल आपके पास है अपने यू मस्त की वैल्यू
सबसे पहले अपने मालवेयर में यूं मास की
वैल्यू चेंज कर दी
समझ गया
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी के अकॉर्डिंग
ठीक है हम आपको यू मास्क की सुविधा दे रहे
हैं लेकिन हमारी पॉलिसी यह है की किसी भी
फाइल को हम भले आप यू मास की वैल्यू कोई
भी चेंज कर लो लेकिन हम किसी भी फाइल को
मैक्सिमम परमिशन
दे सकते हैं
यहां पर कंडीशन डिफाइंड है डिफॉल्ट वाली
तो आप करके देख लेना बहुत लोगों को
अकॉर्डिंग क्या करते हैं की स्टेबल को
कैलकुलेट करेंगे उसके अकॉर्डिंग क्या यू
मस्त की वैल्यू डिसाइड करते हैं तो वो
सोचते हैं की इस फाइल पर बाय डिपल ये
परमिशन देखने को मिल जाएगी लेकिन क्या है
की यहां पर प्रॉब्लम दो है यू मास की
वैल्यू चेंज कर सकते हो नो इशू यू मस्त की
वैल्यू अपना अकॉर्डिंग डिसाइड करता हूं
लेकिन आप की पॉलिसी क्यों ओवरपास नहीं कर
सकते और वो पॉलिसी क्या बोलती है की आपको
फाइल की जो परमीशंस है वो आपका क्या कहना
है 66 दे सकते हो तो इसलिए अगर आपने अगर
यहां पर किसी भी किसी के लिए अगर मैं पर
एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया यू मास की
वैल्यू चेंज कर दी यू मास्क कर सकते हैं
हम चेंज जीरो जीरो कर दिया मैंने 800 कर
दिया अब मैं एक कम कर रहा हूं 5 मिनट करता
हूं
यूको टच किया और को टेस्ट
मैंने किया एक फाइल थ्री
इंटर
ही आपको ये दे रहा है हालांकि अपने जीरो
जीरो दिया मतलब आपने रेड लाइट एग्जीक्यूट
रेड एग्जीक्यूट एग्जीक्यूट यू मस्त डिफाइन
किया है अगर यहां पर मैं क्या करता हूं
एमके दी आई आर करता हूं उसके बाद टेस्ट
दिया है तू करता हूं
उसके बाद टेस्ट दिया है तू करता हूं
अब देखो इसमें पुरी दे दिए इधर डायरेक्ट
फूल डायरेक्टरी को आप देख सकते हो लेकिन
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी के अकॉर्डिंग आप फाइल
को एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन नहीं दे सकते इसलिए
आप यू मास की वैल्यू चाहिए कुछ भी लगा दो
लेकिन आपको कंडीशनल कम करना पड़ेगा ठीक है
आप यू मास्क की वैल्यू कर दी लेकिन भैया
मैं एक कम करूंगा की आपने यू मस्त की
वैल्यू को मैं लेक चलूंगा लेकिन आपको मेरी
पॉलिसी को कंसीडर करना होगा इस हिसाब से
फिर बाय
कंडीशंस को क्या करूंगा मानते हुए
परमिशन डिफाइन करूंगा किसी भी आने वाले
फाइल को क्रिएट करने के लिए तो इसलिए क्या
है की आप लोगों को लगता की मैं कुछ भी रख
दो युवक की वैल्यू और वहां चेंज कर दूंगा
ऐसा नहीं ऐसे अटैक कर भी सो सकता है उसने
चेंज कर दिया लेकिन वो कैसे क्या करेगा
क्योंकि आपकी जो पॉलिसी है वो ये बोलती है
की 66 सी दे शक्ति से ज्यादा मैं आपको
बड़ी डिपोज भाई नहीं करता था टाइगर को
क्या करना पड़ेगा अटैकर को यूजर बन्ना ही
पड़ेगा यूजर बने के लिए उसको क्या करना
पड़ेगा रूट यूजर बन्ना पड़ेगा किसी भी
फाइल को नॉर्मल यूजर बैंक भी कर सकता है
लेकिन क्या उसके होम अकाउंट में कम कर रहे
थे लेकिन अगर आप रूट यूजर बनोगे तब उसको
एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन देनी होगी मालवेयर के
अंदर उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो अटैक कर
पाओगे मशीन के अंदर क्योंकि क्या करता है
की आप किसी भी मशीन की लाइन मशीन के अंदर
कोई
प्रोसेस उनके थ्रू भी इंटर करते हो सिस्टम
के अंदर लिरिक्स जो रिलीज है तो ये है वो
चीज यू मास का खेल जो आपको समझ में ए गया
होगा प्लीज एक बार चैटिंग बता दीजिए
यही वह करण है इलेक्ट्रिसिटी
मैं रिपीट कर दूंगा
स्टार्ट किया है इसको एक बार देख लीजिए
अगर आई प्रॉमिस अगर आपको तब समझ में नहीं
आता की
मैं कल पहले क्लास में आपसे ही पूछ लेट
हूं की आपको मेरा जो नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी
डेट है मैं आपसे पहले पूछूंगा की आपको
क्या क्लियर हुआ नहीं हुआ प्लीज मेरी आंबल
रिक्वेस्ट ये की आपको एक बार क्या कर
लीजिए वीडियो को रिवाइज कर लीजिए इसका
सबको दोबारा ध्यान से सुना साड़ी बटन को
एक बार नहीं दो बार सुना उसके बाद अगर
आपको नहीं समझ में आता तो आई बिल
डेफिनेटली रिपीटेड कोई नो इशू मैं कर
दूंगा मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता जैसे 5
मिनट ज्यादा ले लेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं
आपको कॉन्सेप्ट क्लियर होना चाहिए तो
प्लीज ये मेरी रिक्वेस्ट है
ओके अगर कल समझ में नहीं आता बट यू
प्रॉमिस किया आपको वीडियो को देखना पड़ेगा
पैसे नहीं की आप डायरेक्टली आए फिर से पूछ
लिया सब समझ में नहीं आया क्योंकि मैंने
इतना लेवल भाषा में कॉन्सेप्ट को समझाया
था काफी
और आपको काफी क्लियर हो जाएगा अभी
तो यह कॉन्सेप्ट है और अगर आप एक चीज
बताइए बता देता हूं ठीक है तो चलो अगर
मुझे क्या करना चाहता हूं आपने क्या किया
प्रोफाइल
022 अब पर एग्जांपल ठीक है की आपने हमें
यू मास्क की वैल्यू डिफाइन कर राखी है
सबसे बड़ी परमीशंस आई है लेकिन आप क्या
चाहते हो की नहीं जब मैं कोई भी फाइल लिया
डायरेक्टर को तभी मैं परमिशन अपने हिसाब
से उसे डायरेक्टली फाइल पे रखो ना की मैं
डिफॉल्ट वाली परमिशन अप्लाई करके उसके बाद
मैं क्या करूं
तो आप कैसे क्या कर सकते हो की जैसे की
मैं एक डायरेक्टली करेक्ट कर रहा था एमके
एमके दी आई आर टेस्ट थ्री कर रहा हूं
टेस्ट थ्री दी है डायरेक्टली क्रिएट कर
रहा हूं अब मैं क्या करना है मुझे बाय
डिपो बड़ी परमीशंस को नहीं मानना मुझे
ओवरराइड करना है तो आप कर सकते हो आईफोन
एम मतलब मुझे क्या मॉडिफाई करना है
मॉडिफाई परमिशन मैं क्या देना चाहता हूं
सेवन जीरो जीरो परमीशंस देना चाहता हूं और
ये अब जो परमेश्वर आपको देखने में मिलेगी
एलएस अप है ये अब आपको 700 परमिशन दे
देंगे तो आप क्या कर सकते हो की वो तो
क्या है की आपको बाय डिफरेंट कर रहे हो तो
आपको ओपन मिलेगी अगर आप चाहे तो आप फाइल
या डायरेक्ट क्रिएट करते हो अगर आप और
मिस्टर डिफाइन करना तब आप कर सकते हो दिस
इसे डी एक तरीका ये है ये मैं आपको बताना
चाहता था तो मैंने आज जो सिखाया की फाइल
परमीशंस क्या होती है कैसे किसी भी फाइल्स
की ओनरशिप आप चेंज कर सकते हो कैसे
परमेश्वर चेंज कर सकते हो और यू मास्क का
कॉन्सेप्ट क्या था यू मास्क की वैल्यू
कैसे टोटली डिपेंड करता है डिपेंड करती है
वही आपको सीकर बनाने में एक करण है
करने के बाद भी
प्रॉब्लम आपको
कॉन्सेप्ट आपको क्लियर हो गया होगा और
मुझे लगता है की आज इतना ही करते हैं या
अब आप लोगों के लिए अगर मैं एक चीज बताना
चाहूं अगर आप लोगों ने एक टास्क डन तो
क्या करोगे क्या मैं आप लोग एक प्रैक्टिस
क्वेश्चन डन क्या आप लोग उसको प्रॉमिस करो
की आप उसको करोगे और लिख देंगे पेज भी
भेजोगे
बताइए
सबसे पहले हम आपको प्रैक्टिस क्वेश्चन आज
का रहेगा वो रहेगा
नाम जिसका फाइल का नाम रहेगा
आम डॉट
करनी है
[संगीत]
उसके बाद
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है
[संगीत]
रीड और मॉडिफाइड
तू
मॉडिफाई
तू डी फाइल
ऑन फाइल आम
करनी है
और उसके फर्स्ट स्टेप पर मैं क्या करना है
आपको वेरीफाई करना है
जो मेंबर्स हैं डिस्कशन के ऊपर क्या वो इस
फाइल में मोडिफिकेशन कर सकते हैं या नहीं
कर सकते हैं
आपको क्लियर भी हो गया होगा
इजिप्ट क्लियर और नोट
और मैं उम्मीद करता हूं की जो लोग अभी हैं
हमारे लाइव में
अटेंड तक क्वेश्चन
और रिकॉर्डिंग
रिकॉर्डिंग क्षेत्र देख लिया करो अगली बार
से मैं क्या रिकॉर्डिंग करके आपको भेज
दूंगा सीधा अपलोड कर दूंगा
आज जो आपने पढ़ा प्लीज मेंशन आईटी इस संबल
रिक्वेस्ट सो डेट की बाकी लोगों को आपकी
हेल्प मिले
गुड नाइट सी यू नेक्स्ट एक्शन